hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to what may be the
final episode of huniepop now I was told
that there is another character to
unlock but this character is only
unlocked by dating every girl till 5
hearts are fulfilled and nothing else
happens because everything here is
totally platonic and nothing is bad in
any way so as you can see we need to
just get Nikki to have a fun time on a
final date and then the last character
will be unlocked which I did not know
about until people wrote it in the
comments below before thanks for the
spoiler everybody
Hey did I make that noise Matt what the
hell did I just do
hi Nicki hello well you know exactly
what I'm up to this late because you're
about to find out because we're going to
go on a date together two little things
by business what shoes are stupid why
would I gift a girl some shoes girls
don't like shoes that's stupid and I
know girls girls don't like how many
girls out there actually enjoy shoes
none right it's stupid whatever let's go
on this date I guess that's fine I mean
if you really want to go sure I do but I
do have to wonder why were you so
worried about my sack and why would and
how it was full because that doesn't
come till later in fact nothing comes
till later in fact no one's going
anywhere are you in your pajamas I mean
not that I'm complaining but it seems a
little odd considering we're out on a
date I mean I'm no expert on dating
I'd like to assume I am but really I'm
just a false has no idea what he's doing
with his life what I actually am in
reality is a guy playing a video game
about dating instead of actually going
out in the real world need more passion
level I need way more passion level but
it's not giving me the right need
sentiment but it's got no sentiment
right here's a passion problem
what's passion in this dates got a
passion infusion passion Maiko something
I got full of jokes I got jokes for days
and not good yes oh my god I cannot
waste this this is my one and only okay
I think I can do this it's okay
everything is okay we're going to win
even though I have these two power
tokens and they weren't useful to me in
any way the entire time that we were
dating but don't worry about that my has
caused it so that object is going to be
blessed through Christmas
yes rest for Christmas this is word and
here's the definition Matt there is
resolution assist is definitely a word
don't know why you don't me it means
love that was pure luck
100% luck that was the longest I spend
on a puzzle just like braining my way
through oh boy I can't wait oh it's
gonna be so much fun oh I can't been
waiting for this for a long time don't
like I'm not that good or whatever so
like yeah well don't worry I'll go real
easy on you on this game a Mario Kart
here so let me just get my controller
here you know sometimes when I finish in
first place that's the best way to go
about Mario Kart always letting Marga
bar finish first anyway
hi what are you doing what are you doing
there holding that Mario controller
that's not the proper way to hold a
Mario
Nintendo control you silly Billy I'll
have to teach you how to play properly
later much later alrighty then Oh has
the mouse been active this whole time
damn and I was playing a game where I
needed the mouse to be active oh well
sorry well if you've been living with it
now you can live with it for later I
guess
oh me too Thor sorry I destroyed you so
badly in Mario Kart no need to be sore
about it it's totally ok ok so now if I
try to leave alright
so yeah you're good with women I've been
hearing some very impressive reports
from q1 ports that have me very very
interested you've been with every
beautiful girl in your Township with in
a remarkably short time yes I've never
heard of anything like it before me to
ultimately prove yourself there is one
final challenge again you're looking at
her the love of a goddess you will truly
become a legend
I assure you however that this is no
simple task if you have tried but all
have failed no human has ever known my
embrace
do you like Previn watering cans would
you like a watering can
a watering hand I thought of you real
hard I am sweating profusely let's check
your profile sexualities number A plus
number one well a good thing that's my
best quality I think let's go on a date
are gonna build a bunch dates with you
yes I'm gonna complete this in one
episode one fell swoop you think Venus
stands up a cow sans a chance against me
I'm the man I'm markiplier baby
they call me markiplier the man at least
now they do it's not exactly home but it
is pretty here well shut up sweet
gesture like I care
there you are
Here I am let's go on a date already
hurry the hell up I don't have all day
I didn't even beat her with sexuality
tokens a Cirque de Soleil [ __ ] are
you wearing this is ridiculous I need to
break you down because your egos just a
little too out of control right now
think you can just get away from any
fashion tonic god something like I care
well this lady ever get over her stupid
ego I mean I have a big ego I know this
one come on I like her I don't even need
to talk to her I never talked to her
once this entire time I don't want to
listen to what she has to say I just
want to finish this out and be done yes
it might be you send me a bunch of text
but I haven't been paying attention to
them I'm just gonna go ahead on the
third date because frankly I can't be
bothered to even look at anything okay
let's see what we got let's see what you
got do you have anything match this huh
some of this huh
it seems like I'm gonna punch her in the
face but that's not what I'm gonna do
very closely so try not to mess up why
are you holding your boob what does that
one sag more than the other and you got
to give it a little extra support I mean
I understand that you must be very old
being a goddess and all that but I'll
throw you a bone every once in a while
oh look I win yet again yet again I win
I am the greatest that ever lived as a
man of the highest oh yes when people
look at me they definitely think that
I'm the highest man they've ever seen
that's without a doubt no doubt about
that one you can let go of your boob now
off you go then shut up
I'll be back I'm just gonna make a
circle around the entire lap of the city
and then I'll be back tomorrow morning
I'm gonna do nothing but wind sprints
until then because that's how my
performance is back to the past
I promise everyone out there that's
watching this I am exactly like this in
real life I'm gonna stuff Venus full of
food and drink and she's going to have a
great time Oh probably not I've just
been doing those wind sprints that I
told you about hey would you like
anything stuffed inside your face I mean
food favorite drink is whiskey I should
have known how much liquor do you need
you need every drink at the bar
you got it lady you downed like 15 shots
this doesn't seem nice at all
yes we shall leave then on our date
where things will happen
it'll be Shakespearean because your old
affair all right as long as nobody why
would anyone touch you
why would bat me a thing stop being so
worried about yourself you know what for
good luck shut up I'm gonna look at all
the dirty pictures that you sent me so
stand right there okay don't tell kee
about this before I became a goddess I
used to dance at love clubs a girl has
to pay her way through fairy school some
that doesn't make anything what you were
a fairy doesn't make any sense
Oh Mike you introduced me to your
retractable showerhead it's magnificent
I may have no use for you after all okay
Matt preemptively censor this one just
bring it in bring it in bigger bigger
bigger bigger bigger
okay little more a little more stop good
enough yep that was exactly what it
should have been Wow alright then
goodbye alright
now back to the date hey you can talk
now but not much because I have to work
on something don't ask me what because
frankly I don't even know hope you don't
mind I like to shout all my signature
moves at the top of my lungs before I do
anything
okay I did it I wasn't even paying
attention and I did it okay there we go
oh I gave myself the giggles oh man well
watch out for my signature move oh shut
up I don't want anything to do with that
I'm having a moment here right now so
just be quiet
Matt replace it with replace it with I
don't know I can't think right now I'm
not my brains not working at the moment
so replace it with something I'm the
greatest any other challenge uh huh you
didn't hope that I would be a lot you
seem to be very antagonistic about my
life so how about you get out of my
bedroom
awesome then will you watch I mean I've
heard stories but I've never seen
anybody actually pull it off was she as
good as I imagined not at all not at all
let's see no who's alright you're
killing my dream no you loved it really
I'm not even sure what else to say it
feels like just a couple of days ago you
could barely get a sentence out in front
of a cute girl okay wait work me you'd
still be yourself to sleep if it wasn't
for me good real good
I'm proud of ya there's really only one
place to go from here kind of sex dad
whatever I'll explain it anyway change
in my hair
the difficulty will be locked into the
hard setting dates will continue to
increase in difficulty indefinitely the
question is how far can you get sounds
fun right no but we need to make sure
you're really prepared for it you to
fork over those panties together I need
12 pairs of panties from you each pair
from a different girl already gotta hand
em over how would I not have them I've
been collecting them I've been a weirdo
all my life this is all I do
all I do is collect panties that's all I
do so this is what people meant
I was looking for those hmm not really
though I knew you had to be sick perv I
like these are these are panties this is
like a string that belly girl is a
closet freak I'm telling my nose you
said something individual my god not
listen to you talk about this because
it's even creepier than when I talk
about it now I make it very creepy boys
a porn star your junk starts to itch yet
how do you know I'm not got to do what
you got to do I'm not doing what I got
to do that's it
that's 12 pairs of panties good luck
with nothing okay so that is officially
the end of huniepop I did it everyone
applauded how great of a lover I am man
put up a lot of clapping hands because I
don't think anyone in the comics I do
okay so thank you everybody so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed this series
of depravity because it's been a wild
ride and not a good one but thank you
nonetheless for watching so check out
the description for more cool games that
I played in the past that have nothing
to do with boonies poppies Sexy's or
Muniz or aliens or cats so thanks again
everybody for watching and as always I
will see you